le gouvernement il fait un truc pas
clair l'âge pivot c'est une sorte de
danse du ventre de la ville à la
retraite ils n'ont pas su mais ils n'ont
pas assumé ce une mesure hypocrite et
extraordinairement type qui s'est
pourtant dit aux gens vous avez le droit
de partir à 62 ans
parce que le gouvernement pas le courage
de reculer l'âge mais vous allez partir
avec une petite retraite avec une super
décote
c'est donc une mesure c'est donc une
mesure de réduction des pensions cas
beaucoup de points où je ne comprends
pas pour qu'on a fait si compliqué
pourquoi on fait si compliqué pour qu'on
n'a pas fait quelque chose de plus
simple et plus efficace pour qu'on a
fait autant de gesticulations inutiles
sur le système des retraites français
n'est capable d'expliquer aujourd'hui ce
que le premier ministre a expliqué merci
d'indiquer donc il a mis du temps le
comprends mais cette fois à cette fois